alors que tout le monde ne sait pas
encore qui est mister france va jouer un
petit chiffre est rentrée mais je
quitterais mon premier quatre jeunes
hommes très très bon et parle ou ces
quatre jeunes hommes il y à un mister
france vous allez essayer de trouver qui
mister france
on va procéder par élimination voilà à
les hits fait rentrer les cannoises
merci
parmi ces quatre garçons il y a
mister france je vous demander de voter
chez vous qui y est mister france 1 2 3
qui quatre ans il y en a un qui votent
pour le un oui j'arrête ma carrière
on va se retrouver dans un instant sur
mac et mister france
on fera bien sûr le ski ne fallait pas
louper c'est génial elie mieux moi je
brosse mois non l'état
j'hésite entre eux j'hésite entre deux
trous jeu et je crois qu'il jeu et vous
j'ai pas le sens comme ça c'est vous je
peux pas en parler donc à la française
j'ai posé une question à chacun oui mais
vous allez devoir trouver sherbrooke et
mister france
et vous aussi autour de la table
question en quelle année avez vous été
1912 avec qui s'appelle jade et mister
france
et ben oui tout à fait j'ai été élu à
louhans cuiseaux d'accord voilà et je
suis très content d'être là très fier et
j'ai des formes et couleurs
il est beau on va vous étonner ce que
voulait dire oui mais vous savez
traversons soir quand vous appelez soir
et rousset jan oui question ça pas
question ça va merci
question vous avez été mister france de
vtt ou et qu'est-ce qui a fait que vous
avez été le mr j'ai été vu dans le 77
rien n'est sûr marc bret
à la place la question faites-vous une
idée mais en travaux jours pour vous
appeler david salut david vous êtes
mister france exactement
qu'est-ce qui a fait que vous avez été
mister france l'a beaucoup c'est ouais
c'est brushing le brushing m'a mis très
bien vous avez ça a plu tout de suite
tout de suite ça quoique aux yeux ça
fait tilt ouais bravo
bonsoir vous êtes mister france oui
qu'est-ce qui a fait que vous avez été
mister france
sûrement le sourire souriez finale alors
à votre avis qu'est mister france chibi
robo ce numéro 4 s'est bilal belime
d'hésiter entre 3 et 4 je vais dire 4
d'autres cali moi c'est raide la peau
tannée moyen d'arriver
laissez-moi arriver parmi les quatre
d'accord de cette année oui tomber bayod
10 912 c'est fou tout ça faut tout vous
dire monsieur ça va pas
mais du coup d'accord ok
e
ben ouais je tairai 4 aussi monsieur ce
que vous êtes mister france non question
est ce que vous êtes mister france non
est ce que vous êtes mister france n'en
est ce que vous êtes mister france ô
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est pas la dévotion du boulot merci by
dad 21
vous êtes le maire de la ville et
cérémonial voilà ce qu'il a écrit parce
qu'ils avaient crées miss et mister
leicester france c'est vrai c'est pas
vous êtes content ce cas là je n'avais
léger 25 ans bon c'est beau c'est beau
mister france
ouais c'est magnifique c'est à dire
faire plein de plateau tout faire une
émission avec moi j'aurais bien voulu
faire une émission avec nous avec
plaisir peut-être ben voila moi on va on
va le cas du très vite ça offrait donc
est ce que c'est vous est ce que vous
êtes célibataire
bah oui mais pourquoi vous dites oui bah
oui quand et mister france était
forcément célibataire gt2 bien utile de
venir